i think yeah but i think like trash
taste has definitely done a good job
with like you know to varying levels uh
or or varying results like trust's kind
of like gotten us to kind of look at our
main channel stuff and being like i
could probably change is it actually a
main channel is it like i just say main
i didn't even think of any channel as
the main channel i'm just like i just
make [ __ ] some of it has priority over
the other ones yeah but it depends week
by week which i'm prioritizing because
because like part of the reason why i've
been uh putting down the uh not not like
i've been putting the same amount of
videos on the main channel now which is
two videos a month and i'm not going to
try to do more because i want to do two
videos a month huh i thought you did one
a month no i only did i only do one a
month when it's uh when it's like
apologizing
yeah yeah so yeah yeah so right now i'm
doing two videos a month um and i'm
putting all my extra time into i do also
want to like make a second channel
because that seems fun you know
it's
i see you guys doing it and i'm just
like you know what maybe my main channel
doesn't need to be my top priority you
know i've got like the formula down for
my main channel and now i just want to i
just want this extra time to do other
[ __ ] now because i was thinking because
i have like a lot of ideas for like big
projects that can go to my main channel
right which which i am sitting on
um but my god they're going to take so
much [ __ ] time
um and i'm like doing these big projects
really takes a lot out of you especially
when you're also trying to maintain your
const consistent upload
schedule on your main channel anyway
yeah yeah so i've kind of come to
realize that you know when i really
really feel like i'm down on youtube and
i need to work on a video where i'm pr
that i'm really passionate in then i'm
going to start doing those but for now
like i want like i want to do more more
small stuff i want i want to i want to
do yeah
i think the thing for me was i it was a
you know because i
i'm not sitting here saying that my main
channel is quality by any means i think
there is some level of effort that goes
into it and uh i'm going to harsh myself
would that not be quality yeah
i don't know there is a certain point
there's a certain bar that i try to do
on the channel for most videos there's
sometimes like i did like a [ __ ]
which chris loves to joke about yeah my
monkey tls video which i just wanted to
do because i thought it was it was fun
but it's obviously you know it's not
it's nothing like exceptional yeah but
you know in general the videos that i
have were quite difficult but you know
sometimes i see someone doing like a you
laugh you lose challenge i'm like that
seems fun i'd like to do that yeah i'll
do it live instead i'll do it on the the
other channel because it works and so it
kind of came to a point where a lot of
fun ideas that just weren't
big enough or weren't uh exciting enough
to like
warrant putting a lot of time and effort
into that yeah just kind of work really
well on the other side
because that's that's what i've noticed
well that's why i want that's why i want
a second channel because i feel like i
have set a bar of quality on my main
channel and i've like tested
uploading videos that maybe have not had
as much time put into them and use you
do see it in the view numbers if um like
eventually so that's why i'm just like
okay let's just keep my main channel for
like the contents big boy videos for the
big boy videos for the videos that my
audience expect to me but that doesn't
mean you can't do other things on the
second channel yeah it's like you know
there's like so many like especially
timely things or you know like so many
things that perhaps have nothing to do
with the [ __ ] i'm known for right that i
want to talk about in the video like you
know when youtube brought out that news
that they were going to get rid of the
dislike button right he's like i want to
talk about this in a video but i can't
just put up a 15-minute rant of me on
the channel about it all right so it's
like perfect i have a perfect outlet for
random [ __ ]
have you how many do you get the
comments of i don't watch the anime
anymore watch joey yeah a lot
i mean you know that's fine and
everything because it's like you know at
the end of the day it's still me right
so it's it's whatever and you know it's
weird right because especially this past
like two or three weeks uh i've been
uploading a lot more on the second
channel and i've just like i found
myself waking up and thinking to myself
all right what should the next channel
on the second channel oh the next video
on the second channel
oh wait wait i have a main channel [ __ ]
i should probably think about that one
as well right i think because another
big thing as well is um i feel like
right now with my main channel it i've
definitely seen the plateau of just that
kind of anime content yeah like that
kind of amazing concept and you know i i
do i do have like ideas about how you
know you can i could i could keep that
channel growing and grow past the
plateau but the the amount of time and
effort that would take
would to to me that would take too much
time and effort that i just don't have
right now that would take giving up
trash taste basically yeah to uh to make
content and rebrand my channel to a
point where it can grow plus past the
plateau of that kind of vanity content
right how do you feel about the growth
on your channel your main channel uh i
mean i'm i'm fine with it because
because i know like right now annie tube
as it is has just plateaued like that's
you know we've seen the plateau if if
there are any other antitubers who would
like to prove me wrong please because
you know i'm i'm waiting for that one
person to prove me wrong yeah i i'm
waiting as well because i need i need to
kick up my ass to be like oh you can go
higher okay that's like my motivation
because like i'm sure your you guys are
the same way it doesn't matter how many
subscribers you have right what i find
what i find happiness in is growing
something or like making making it feel
like i have made progress on something
so like i felt way more fulfilled seeing
the progress and growth on trash taste
than i did on my own channel for like
last year yeah and like that's why i'm
the
thought of a second channel excites me
way more than even making big videos on
my own channel because even if i make a
big video my own channel which i'm
really passionate in i know that there's
a certain cap for like the number of
views that's going to get and i mean
it's already like you know especially
with like all of our main channels like
it's it's already at a size where we're
pretty
happy with right and it's like it's it's
massive to a lot of people right so it's
like yeah yeah it's just it just makes
more sense that like you know obviously
you're gonna have more excitement
watering this tiny plant than watering a
giant tree right yeah obviously watching
this tiny thing grow into something
bigger is going to be more fulfilling
especially if you're trying to do
something that you otherwise not really
known for perhaps it's like content that
you've never tried before and stuff like
that and i think that's why i've been
having so much fun with the second
channel but like yeah i don't know like
and so like my main channel grew as well
like i hit three million subs this year
yeah um
yeah
yeah you did it as well
it does it doesn't feel like a broken
law yeah right but like to me it's like
i don't know like i know definitely past
me would look at some months of my
channel's growth and being like oh man i
didn't really grow that much at all but
like i think i've just rewired my brain
this year to be like if it ain't a
negative then it's all good dude like if
if every day i'm gaining at least one
sub i'm i'm completely okay with that
now because i haven't been canceled yet
yeah exactly it's like if if people are
still like looking at my [ __ ] and
wanting to come in
cool dude like my doors are open but
like i'm not i'm not at this point now
where i'm like oh [ __ ] i only made 20
000 subs this month i'm i'm slowly dying
you know it's like yeah the channel yeah
i'm like don't chance like oh no i'm
just past that point now like i'd much
rather put in the time to like be like
oh i have this tiny second channel that
i want to grow into something big so
let's let's focus on that kind of thing
or you know with like trash taste for
instance right yeah yeah
like like that that's way more exciting
for me and i think that's why you know
at least you and i have had a lot of fun
doing the second stuff right because
it's just like streaming it's just
something new right it's fun yeah did
you start like properly streaming this
year or did it start last year i can't
remember it it almost feels like you've
been streaming forever like properly
properly like consistently i think it
was this year right it's been more this
year than it was like well last year it
was 2009 no 2009 when was the chess
tournament the first one
uh early 2020 yeah 2020. okay well 2020
was around when i started streaming okay
and then i think yeah this year is
probably where it's growing the most
i've been a lot more consistent been
doing a bunch of stuff with that yeah
it's interesting
i still occasionally get people coming
into the twitch being like i had no idea
you had a twitch channel yeah oh yeah
yeah i have that every time i stream
yeah
i guess it's a different platform right
yeah it is a different platform yeah